well one goal that's been in progress
for a long time among activists is being
pursued with gusto during this shutdown
and that's the plan to empty the
nation's prisons recently a California
federal judge ordered immigrants to be
released from ice detention if they are
medically quote vulnerable which by the
way would describe like most of the
country at this point one beneficiary of
that order was a man called Martin
Vargas Rea no he was released for having
diabetes and hepatitis C he is a sex
offender he's guilty of child
molestation lewd and lascivious acts
with a minor
another diabetic immigrant Paolo rayon
Vita was convicted despite a conviction
for child abuse so apparently that's a
standard now until we have a vaccine for
coronavirus and who knows when that'll
be we have to release child molesters as
long as they have diabetes meanwhile
people are being threatened with jail
for going outside without permission you
just saw a thority in Florida arrests a
minister for having a church service so
they put the Christian in prison they
let the child molester out o in Virginia
you saw a shopkeeper
imprisoned he's there without bail for
the crime of defending himself against
burglars by the way he has diabetes too
he just collapsed from it they're
keeping him without bail that's the
progressive paradise this rate they
won't want to cure for coronavirus
because they're enjoying it so much I
shouldn't have said that that I ever
wants a cure for cars but they should
not be using this moment